Well. Hello Google. Thank
you so much for having me.
It's brilliant to see you all here.
I'm only slightly disappointed
that there's no dogs in
the audience because that
would have been completely awesome,
but maybe next time we have a burger
you can all bring your dogs in.
That would be amazing. Um, so yeah,
I'm here to talk about my book,
bring back the king,
the new science of de Extinction,
which is all about as kit said,
the ability of scientists to bring
extinct animals back to life.
And it's a science and that's
very much in development.
It's not quite with us now, but I think
it will be with us reasonably. See,
uh,
and this is,
you can see is the book
here is my dog Higgs.
He's modeling the book, therefore you,
just to give you an idea of sample copies,
he's called, he's called
Higgs, the dog particle,
which is a joke that
you guys at Google gap,
which I can leave you love cause people
would normally look at me and stare
blankly at that point. So that is
Higgs before he read the book. And
that is Higgs. Afterwards, I think
he found it quite satisfying,
quite exhausting. Uh, so he's
my promo dog, which is good. So,
um, the book asks, which animal
would you like to bring back?
And I'm doing an event at
new scientists this weekend,
and we put out a thing on Twitter just
to gauge people's reaction to this.
We said, what animals from the
past would you like to resurrect?
Just to get a feeling of where
people were with this topic?
And sample answers included the great org.
Good example, a smiler dawn,
which is a saber tooth cat.
Interesting. And somebody said, I'd
like a pet velociraptor, please.
Which kind of intrigued me.
So I tweeted them back and I said,
why a pet velociraptor?
And the guy said,
because I fancy a pet
with retractable claws,
which is kind of interesting. So I tweeted
him back and I said, how about a cat?
And he tweeted me back and said,
I'm not a cat person.
So there we are. And you'll notice
also, I've, uh, anonymized these tweets.
Clearly I'm not just followed by people
that have Guinea pig avatars. I've just,
so there we are, um, uh,
other sample answers just quickly before
I moved on include can they make a half
man half woolly mammoth,
which is interesting cause I think I've
been living with that particular thing
for about the last 10 years.
He's called a man off to
see what I've done that um,
somebody else said, Margaret
Thatcher clones, thousands of them,
millions,
an army
slightly disconcerting.
That's not what the extinction is about.
And then somebody hit the nail on
the head almost when they said Dojo.
Then I farmed them and
start a fast food chain.
Dodos Kf d Dodo cottage,
which was a good joke,
but was topped when somebody else tweeted
Nando days. Genius. Absolute genius. Okay.
So let me tell you about the extinction.
I want to start by telling you a
story and it's a story about a goat,
but this wasn't any usual kind of goat.
Uh,
this was a goat that lived in the Pyrenees
thousands of years ago and these were
amazing animals. They
were big, stocky beasts.
They weighed about as much as a washing
machine, but they were much more agile.
And have these enormous,
great big curved horns.
And what they used to do is they used
to spring around on the mountain sides
casting impressive horn silhouettes
against the clear blue sky cloudless sky.
And they did that brilliantly familiar
with thousands of years until we came
along at the end of the 19th century.
And we looked at them and we looked at
their horns and we looked at our empty
living room walls, and you'll have to
remember this within a time before Ikea.
So there was no to go to buy
reasonably priced pictures or frames.
So our walls were empty
at that point in time.
So they looked at it be Kardos horns.
They looked at that empty living
room walls and they thought,
do you know what that would
look really good there,
which is a shame.
So we started hunting them
and their numbers plummeted.
So then if you fast forward to the year,
1999 there was only one left,
one bucardo and that was an
elderly adult female called Celia.
And scientists knew that
her time was running out.
They knew they had to do something.
So they went up on the mountain side and
they caught Celia and they put a radio
tracking collar around her neck and then
they let her go and they kept an eye on
her to see what she was up to.
And then the next year,
the radio tracking collar let
out an ominous beep, beep beep.
And it was the signal
they had been dreading.
They rushed up the mountain to find her,
only to discover that Celia had
been crushed by a falling tree.
Can have an office, Celia, thank you.
So they'd be Cardo was no more,
it had three east to be,
it was an extinct Bucardo and that was it.
And that should be it.
That's, that's what happens when animals
go extinct. That should be the end of it,
except that increasingly that
doesn't have to be the case anymore.
So actually if you rewind a bit to the
point when they put the tracking collar
around her neck, they did
something else. The scientists,
they actually took a couple of biopsy
samples from the animal and they carted
them away and they froze down
herselves in liquid nitrogen.
And then a couple of years after she died,
they thought these cells and they did
the kind of experiment with them that a
few years earlier had been
used to make Dolly the sheep.
Now are you guys familiar with Dolly
the sheep? I'm guessing you are.
So here she is. I just want to side
track and talk about Dolly for a second.
So Dolly the sheep was of course the
thirst mammal to be cloned from an adult's
out and she showed that you
can take the DNA from an adult,
so add it into an egg that's had its own
DNA removed and then use that to create
life.
And that was the nominal.
So jolly became this huge media sensation.
The pepper APTC literally
followed her every move.
So here she is on the front
cover of Nature magazine.
Shortly after she was born,
then he or she is a few years later
on the front cover of Hello magazine.
Uh, and then a few years after that,
sadly
on the cover of Waitrose food illustrated
with a little rosemary and garlic,
no
where she's ended up, she stuffed
and she is in a museum in Scotland.
That's our final resting place.
God rest her little fleecy soul.
So that was the experiment that
inspired the Bucardo scientists. Okay.
So they did the same kind of experiment
and then in 2003 after hundreds and
hundreds of attempts,
something incredible happened.
And this is the actual
moment when it happened.
So they created a little baby be
Comado Celia's identical clone.
So this is the moment that de
extinction actually first happened.
And this was actually over 10 years ago,
which most people don't realize.
So it was a phenomenal achievement.
Phenomenal.
And she was beautiful. This little
clone, she was gorgeous. She had towels,
all the brown stair and wonky
legs and toffee colored eyes.
But unfortunately she
developed breathing problems.
And then she died just a couple
of minutes after she was born.
So they'd be Cardo isn't just the
first animal to become extinct.
It's also the first animal
ever to go extinct twice,
which is a bit of a shame.
But I spoke to the scientists who were
involved in this particular piece of work
and they absolutely assure me
that with time and with funding,
those are the two limiting factors.
They are completely convinced they
will be able to bring the Bucardo back,
not just one,
but many healthy be Kardos that they'd
like to see released into their former
range.
So I don't know how that makes you feel,
but that story leaves
me with mixed emotions.
I feel pretty sad that we
treated that Bicharto so badly,
but I feel really excited
for what might be possible.
And I want to show you my
favorite photograph of me ever.
So this is me on the beach at
charm earth as Kipp mentioned,
and I'm a little dude on the right hand
side in the Austin Red Wellie boots.
And I'm about two years old
and we used to go down there,
fossil hunting and the Rock,
there are 198 million years old.
They were formed at a
time when there were huge,
great big reptilian sea
monsters in the sea,
pterosaurs in the sky and
dinosaurs on the land.
And it made me dream about
bringing back a dinosaur.
So when you think about the extinction,
you think about what might be possible.
And I began to wonder,
could you bring back a dinosaur?
And if you did bring back a dinosaur,
to my mind,
there's only one contender
and it's this t rex.
It has to be a t rex,
right once described as the
absolute warlord of the jungle.
It's teeth have in the
scientific literature,
quite humorously been
described as lethal bananas.
So if ever,
there's two words that don't go together.
I think it's lethal and banana or
possibly Trump and white house,
also quite bad. So I was really
interested, can you bring a dinosaur back?
So I spoke to the scientists and they
tell me, it boils down to one rule,
magic ingredient,
which is this DNA.
And here is some that I knitted earlier.
So DNA is a very beautiful molecule,
but it's very flimsy. It's very fragile.
And after we die,
it begins to breakdown.
And in exceptional circumstances it
can be preserved for a long time.
But the oldest thing we
have ever extracted DNA from
meaningful amounts of DNA
from is less than a million years old.
So dinosaurs died out 65
million years ago. So no DNA,
no dinosaurs, sorry. So we're
not going to see a dinosaur.
The closest thing we will ever get to
a living, breathing dinosaur is this,
which is my dog in a dinosaur onesie.
Shortly before he called the Irs Pca.
So now it's dinosaurs.
The other question I get from people
is, how about these, how about Joe dies?
And I have to see these
beautiful illustrations,
which are in the book or the work of a
guy called Matt Dawson who is fantastic.
And so this is his Dodo.
Could you bring a Dodo back?
Now they died much more recently. So in
theory it might be a bit more possible.
However,
where they lived in malicious was very
hot and the soil where they fell when
they died was very acidic. So that
DNA is not preserved. So no DNA,
no dodos.
Sorry about that,
but he got this idea going in my head
when I was thinking about the book and I
thought, so he can't do
dinosaurs. You can't do dodos.
You need something from
much more recent history.
How far could you take this technology?
Where could you go with it?
And I began wondering about this man,
Elvis Presley.
Amanda deemed so sexy by the TV stations
of the fifties that they refuse to show
him from the waist down.
He was too damn sexy.
And I began to wonder, could you,
I don't think it's a good idea.
I am not saying that we should do this,
but as a thought experiment
with the technology we have,
could this be possible?
And then I came across this website,
genuine,
genuine website,
Americans for cloning.
Elvis founded by a guy called Bob Mayer,
who I spoke to you for the book,
alarmingly banned on Facebook and they
have a petition you can sign if you think
cloning is a good plenty.
Elvis is a good idea.
And quite a lot of people have signed
it. How serious they are. I don't know.
Anyway,
the good thing about this website is it
gives you a couple of ideas of starting
places for Elvis is DNA.
Cause if you want to bring back Elvis,
you need a source of his DNA.
So the first possible source
of Dna they recommend is this.
These are toenails.
So there's a lady called Joanie Mae and
she runs a museum in America and she was
going through gracelands shortly after
Elvis Presley died and she went through
his man cave room is man Dan and had a
carpet like this but dark green shag pile
carpet.
And she kind of got down to her knees
at one point and started just feeling
around the carpet,
maybe a bit odd but hey and I think a
snagged on something and she picked it up
thinking it was like a way would seek
Quinn or something and it was dark.
So she popped it in her pocket and when
she got outside she discovered it was a
toenail.
Now toenails are good sources of DNA.
They preserve it really, really well.
But you guys are probably ahead of me.
This isn't an obvious choice for bringing
back Elvis because what if it didn't
belong to Elvis?
What if it belonged to some American
Doris wearing open toed sandals?
It's an awful lot of trouble to go to.
So we scratched that off the list,
but they have another source of DNA.
And this is Joanie maybes prize
possession in her Elvis Museum.
It's the Elvis wart.
So in that little test tube,
there is a test tube of
formaldehyde and it has a wart.
Now Elvis Presley used to have a water
on the back of his hand and before he
went into the military service,
the water was removed.
And his doctor had the foresight to say
that this is in the days before a bay.
So it was quite forward thinking.
And then it was purchased by the lady
from the museum. And I thought, well,
maybe we could get DNA from this
and we could get DNA from this,
but warts are caused by viruses.
So this DNA is going to be a
mix of human and viral DNA.
So we don't want to go that either.
So I kind of ground to a halt.
And then I thought, well hang
on a minute. How about this?
How about Elvis Presley's
famous iconic quiff, right? Hey,
it's a really, really good source of
DNA. What would happen if we did that?
And I went onto ebay out of curiosity
and I put in the phrase celebrity hair
cause I was intrigued to
see what would come up.
And it's really
interesting if you do that.
If you put in the phrase celebrity hair,
you can buy locks of hair that
belonged to all sorts of people,
including Abraham Lincoln,
Princess Diana and Michael Jackson,
presumably from before the
Pepsi Commercial. Don't
know if you remember that.
You can buy hair from Elvis Presley.
And I'd just like to read
you if you'll humor me,
a small excerpt from my
book of what happened when I
actually bought a sample of
Elvis Presley's hair on Ebay.
So this is chapter six, the king of
rock and roll. It goes like this.
When it finally arrived,
I was more than a little disappointed
sometime earlier I had bought some of
Elvis Presley's hair on Ebay and like a
child waiting for Christmas had then had
to endure weeks of over
excitement and speculation.
While I waited for my purchase to turn up,
I was expecting something as
iconic as the king himself.
The package I told myself would at the
very least be made of gold army and
studied in rhinestones.
It would arrive with great ceremony
serenaded on by its own backing band,
well done by the friends
he'd scream of female fans.
He would camp outside my house
and faint when the parcel arrived,
but when the postman finally delivered my
precious cargo, it was without fanfare.
He didn't even ring the bell.
He just popped the plain,
that brown envelope through
the letterbox and walked away.
I picked up the drab and elvisy
anticlimax and turned it over in my hands.
Save for the Memphis postmark smudged
across the top right hand corner.
There was little hint as to the imports,
legendary contents,
perhaps things would be more
promising on the inside.
I told myself brimming with
nervous energy, all shook up even.
Do you see what I've done?
I carefully open the envelope
and teased out the contents,
but the luxuriant quiff of my dreams
was nowhere to be seen. Instead,
I found myself staring at an a four
sized certificate of authenticity.
You are now the proud owner of a
genuine strand of Elvis Presley's hair.
The certificate crowed,
but where was the hair?
Perhaps they had forgotten to include
it or maybe it was being sent. Sent,
sent separately and armed
guard from Graceland.
I scoured the shoddily photocopied piece
of paper for a claim and it was only
then that I noticed a blob of dried
glue at the bottom of the page.
Inside it like an insect trapped in
amber was a short strand of hair.
I stared at it, unable to
believe what my eyes were seeing,
incapable of processing
what I held in my hands.
Words actually failed me.
Not only was the strand miniscule smaller
even than a single eyelash from my
face, it was also, and I can't
bring myself to say this,
Ginger Elvis Presley.
If the certificate was to be believed
with strawberry blonde as the penny
dropped,
I felt so lonesome I could cry.
I had spent $14 90 and enjoy the longer
wait than the kings fans had for his
comeback tour only to receive what
appeared to be Ronald Mcdonald's nasal
clippings.
So we did the only thing I could think of,
I seals the certificate back
up in its original envelope,
found a thick black marker
pen and wrote upon it,
returned to sender,
adding that the address was unknown.
The irony I was sure would be lost on
them, but it put a smile back on my face.
Then bright and early the next
morning I sent my letter back.
Oh, one person. Thank you very much.
So listen, Elvis Presley, I was
so intrigued with this idea.
I phoned up a scientist, he works
in de extinction and I said to him,
can you do extinct Elvis Presley?
Tell me.
And he thought about it for a
while and then he said, yes,
people have been cloning
pop stars for decades.
And I said, you know what? You're
right. Obviously, because Simon cow,
he produced one direction, didn't
he? And the scientists said yes.
And that is the reason that human
cloning must never be allowed.
So it must never be allowed for
all sorts of genuine ethical,
moral health and safety reasons.
And also because it leads
to the production of songs
like you don't know you're
beautiful.
So with that I put the Elvis idea to bed.
Okay. De Extinction is not
about bringing back dinosaurs.
It is not about bringing back the king
of rock and roll. That was just my whim,
my folly. And then I started
exploring de extinction more deeply.
And that's what I want
to talk to you about now.
So there are genuinely about half a
dozen de extinction projects that are
ongoing around the globe now trying to
bring back different endangered species
of animals.
This is one of them.
This is an animal called
gastric brooding frog.
And what you've got here is a big
frog with a little frog in its mouth.
Now the big frog isn't eating the little
frog, it's actually giving birth to it.
So this is a frog that was discovered
in 1973 in the babbling Brooks of
Queensland, Australia. And what
would happen is the female,
we'd like her acts and then the mail
would come along and fertilize them.
Then the female would eat them,
she'd swallowed them,
they pass into her stomach,
which we would,
she would convert into a makeshift
womb and then the x would hatch,
turn into tadpoles,
turned into frog legs.
She could have about 20 in
her belly at any one time.
And when the time was right, she would
literally button them up literally.
And this is the subject of a de
extinction project in Australia under the
guidance of a guy called Mike Archer.
And the guy who kept these animals in
his lab in the 70s before they went
extinct,
had the foresight to save some body parts
in the freezer and they're using those
for cloning.
So that's one project.
This is another project that you're
all probably a bit more familiar with.
There are the wonderful wooly,
mammoth,
the iconic species from the last ice age.
Now the woolly mammoth is a good
candidate for the extinction.
Maybe because we have
plentiful sources of its DNA,
it's quite commonplace to find tusks
and teeth and bones in the melting
permafrost of Siberia.
And sometimes sometimes scientists
come across stuff like this.
Okay,
so this might not look like much,
but this is actually pretty much the
entire torso of a woolly mammoth that was
found in a remote Siberian island in 2012
and when they looked at it at autopsy,
they realize that not only
did it have fur and hair,
it had skin and flesh and muscle,
and when they cut into it,
I spoke to one of the scientists
who was at the autopsy.
It said it looked like it had fresh meat.
It looked like it was a fresh beef steak.
So well preserved was it?
This animal was frozen continuously
for the last 40,000 years.
And there are three different groups of
scientist trying to bring back the wooly
mammoth and the first two hoping
to use carcasses like this,
get cells from them and use the
DNA inside those cells for cloning.
Right. And that's an amazing
thing to try. However,
as an XL biologist myself,
I'm slightly skeptical
because these mammas had been
frozen for a very long time
with no kind of protective chemicals to
protect the cells like we would do if we
were freezing cells in a lab.
So the cell shatter the DNA leaks away.
It's quite a tall order.
But fortunately there is a third group
who were trying to bring back the wooly
mammoth. And if I have to put my
faith in one particular group,
it's this group and it's led by a guy
called George Church. He works at Harvard.
And my faith in George Church is
based on two particular reasons.
The thirsty is that he is a
remarkably intelligent guy.
He has a brain the size of the planet,
he is so innovative.
He has this amazing genetics lab kitted
out with all the latest stuff and an
army of people working for him
who are equally as brilliant.
And the secondary reason is that he
has this enormous gray, bushy beard.
So he looks a lot like God.
So if I'm gonna put my faith in one group,
it's going to be the one led by the guy
that looks like he would belong on the
roof of the Sistine Chapel.
And he's not trying to clone a mammoth.
He's trying to do something different.
So what he's doing is he's
getting elephant cells and
then he's editing mammoth
genes into elephant cells.
And he's using this technique of the
moment that's everyone's buzzing about
called CRISPR cas nine which enables
scientists to edit genomes with pinpoint
precision.
So he's taking the genes that made the
mammoth mammoth like in different to
elephants genes that
control the growth of their,
for their big thick rolls
of subcutaneous fat.
And they're special hemoglobin that's
steroid oxygen round at low temperatures
and they're putting them in to elephant
cells and they're going to use those to
create life. And I wish him
well. And a third project is,
this is centered around this bird,
the passenger pigeon.
Now this is a bird that's really well
known in America where it used to live
before it went extinct. It went extinct
at the beginning of the 20th century.
But before that for tens
of thousands of years,
the passenger pigeon existed
in fast mind boggling numbers.
It was a beautiful athletic bird and a
flock could contain billions of birds,
I thought could be a hundred
miles long and a mile wide.
It could take days to pass overhead.
And when it did, it blotted out the sun.
They were like an avian eclipse
and then one day they were gone.
Pardon me?
And the scientist he's trying to bring
them back is using this same gene editing
technology to try and do that and
some very clever cell biology.
So there's three of the
projects that are ongoing.
But of course the most
important question is this, why?
Why are scientists trying to do
this? What is the point, right?
And that is a really,
it's the most important question to ask.
And there are lots of reasons why
personally I think de extinction might be
worth a shot.
The first is this,
if you think about the
animals we've just mentioned,
think about the causes
of their extinction.
The gastric brooding frog went extinct
because it's suffered from something
called the caterer had
fungus. And in fact, in fact,
amphibians all around the globe are being
affected by this fungus and there's a
massive amphibian die off going on and
we're spreading that fungus around the
globe through the commercial
transport and trade in Amphibians.
Humans were implicated in the
demise of the woolly mammoth.
It may not have been
exclusively our fault,
but we were implicated
and the passenger pigeon,
we shot every single last
one of them out of the sky.
So you could argue that where we've
played a role in the downfall of a species
and where we have the technology
to do something about it,
maybe we have a moral obligation. And
I think that's an interesting argument.
I think it's good,
but I don't think it's enough.
So when you think about extinctions,
people tend to think about
things from the distant past.
I think about Dodos and dinosaurs,
but actually of course extinction
is happening all around us today.
We live in a time of mass extinction
where extinction rates are spiking in the
time we've been in this room together
and no other species has gone.
And extinction rates are a thousand
times higher than during prehuman times.
So this is our fault and why it's
important is because all living things are
part of an ecosystem.
And I think of ecosystems
as games have giant Jenga.
You know the game where you stack the
bricks and you have to take them away.
What does he take the bricks away?
Or you take the species away for a while,
everything's kind of fine, but then
it gets wobbly and then it crumbles.
But because we're in a mass extinction,
a period of mass extinction,
it's not just like playing
a game of giant Jenga.
It's like playing a game of
giant Jenga with a toddler.
It's all going to come crashing down.
So it's important. Think about
what we might learn along the way.
If we could work out how the gastric
brooding frog changed its stomach into a
wound, we might be able to work out
new therapies for stomach ulcers,
people recovering from stomach surgery.
And if you go for animals that are unique,
genetically unique,
like the gastric brooding frog,
you don't just put a twig
back on the tree of life.
You replenished an entire branch.
So I think for me de extinction is
about restoring lost biodiversity.
That's the key.
It's about putting animals to extinction
is not about making lonely is Eric's
habits.
It's about making healthy genetically
diverse populations of animals that could
be returned to the wild where they
could interact with their ecosystem in a
positive and meaningful way.
And that is a tall, tall order.
We need to think about what we do very,
very carefully.
But in my last five minutes I just
like to mention something else.
So I have to extinction is
about increasing biodiversity
there.
Maybe it's a form of conservation maybe.
And I put a cup of Chamomile tea
here cause when I make this point,
sometimes I get shouty
tweets from conservationists,
he'd get very angry with me and they
say well the extinction and conservation
that completely distinct,
you can't lump them together.
You can't because conservation is about
helping the living and the extinction is
about the debt.
And I think that is a reasonable point.
I don't have a problem with that.
But there are two points that I
make it that the first is this.
If we can get DNA from
museum specimens like this,
surprise looking cat,
right,
or from mammoth teeth or from a pickled
Tasmanian Tiger in a jar and we can get
DNA from all these things.
If we can take DNA from sales that came
from endangered species that have been
frozen away,
if we can get DNA from that and we
can use that DNA to create life,
then maybe some types of creatures
aren't quite as extinct as others.
Maybe there are different
degrees of extinct tennis.
And I think that's a really,
really interesting concept.
So dinosaurs are well and truly extinct.
They're never coming back,
but we've suddenly got this
blurry spectrum between
life and death that didn't
exist before. And that fascinates
me. And the other point is this,
apart from my dog, this is probably
my favorite animal on the planet.
This is a northern white rhino and there
were just three of these animals left
three and I live in a wildlife reserve
in Kenya and as a grandfather and mother
and a daughter,
but they are too old to l and
two related to breed naturally.
So basically they are
functionally extinct.
Here are animals that are alive but
that are the walking dead that ghosts.
So if we do nothing,
they're extinct already.
So I would argue that attempts to bring
back the northern white rhino count as
the extinction is a form of conservation
and there was a guy who works out of
Berlin called Thomas Hildebrandt.
He was doing some amazing work trying
to save the northern white rhino using
some of these new high tech techniques.
And I'd like to leave you
with one final thought.
If we're prepared to think
about the extinction,
if we're prepared to at least consider
in the future that it might be a positive
force,
I think why stop there?
How about if we accept us, we
must, that the world is changing,
that it's warming, that habitats
are changing. How about for example,
we use these gene editing techniques
that we have to improve the fate of the
endangered species on our planet.
What about if when scientists bring
back the gastric brooding frog,
they add in some genes to
make it resistant to the
catch with fungus that would
kill it if we released it into the wild
today. Maybe that's worth thinking about.
Maybe we could engineer fish to be
able to survive rising temperatures.
And this is another very cute animal.
This is the black footed ferret.
These animals currently all living black
footed ferrets today are descended from
seven founder members.
They're very,
very inbred and there the subjects at
a massive captive breeding project.
But when they're released into the wild,
they die because that's a disease
out there that's not billing them.
Cool sylvatic plague.
So plans are afoot to edit
genetic diversity back into
the black footed ferret
and plans are afoot to edit in genes that
confer resistance to the disease that
is killing it.
And the black footed ferret could
possibly become the very first genetically
altered wild animal.
It's something that the FDA in America,
uh, sorry. Not the FDA, the American
authorities are considering.
So there we are de extinction. I don't
want you to go away with a message,
but it's about to happen tomorrow. It's
not. But the science is moving at a very,
very quick pace.
And I believe this is possible and de
Extinction won't stop with the birth of
the first healthy deer extinct animal.
That will be the beginning of a long
process that we'll see these animals
nurtured in captivity for a short while.
There'll be able to grow up check
to make sure they're healthy,
check to see that they can
breed naturally. And then,
and this is the most
difficult parts of all,
probably released into the wild under
the guidance of the colleges where you
would hope they would
flourish and interact with
the environment in a positive
way.
So we have at our fingertips
these incredible processes,
gene editing,
stem cell biology,
assisted reproduction that cannot
only bring back extinct species.
They can also sculpt the
future of life on our planet.
And I'd like to finish with a quote,
which I think is particularly
relevant at this point.
I think it was Spiderman's uncle who
wants said with great power comes great
responsibility. So I think
we need to consider our next
move very, very carefully.
Thank you very much for listening.
Okay,
so we have some time for
questions and I'll take the money.
If you could speak into my
phone, it would be great. Okay.
You say that a human cloning has
understandably been outlawed. Um,
where
does the boundary lie?
Would we be allowed to be a
DX stinked neanderthals off,
strip it if it gets the
amendment and other such Hobo?
That's really interesting actually.
So there's a chapter in the book about
them that you just mentioned. Uh,
that includes me under tiles. And it's
very interesting because of course,
human cloning,
human reproductive cloning is widely band,
not in every country, but in most
developed countries and rightly so.
But actually when those laws were being
drawn up and nobody was even thinking
about pre humans and they're all
currently, as I understand it,
no laws forbidding cloning on the
Undertale because it's not a homo.
Now, I think by extension as we
learn more and more about towels,
we're learning that these
weren't some primitive savages.
These were very sophisticated
people for their time.
They'd been around much longer than us
and we're capable of doing some amazing
things. They were very, very
human for want of a better word.
And I don't think cloning a
neanderthal is a good idea at all.
But what's interesting is that we find
the technology in theory is there to make
it happen and currently there's no
legislation in place to stop it from
happening, but no scientist in
their right mind is considering it.
It's I am pleased to say,
and I don't think anybody ever should.
Thanks.
Do you think we should have any concerns
about a number of hybrid species being
produced as a results of gene editing?
Wow,
I think that's an interesting question.
If we start putting genes in twin
day and to the species first,
don't, we're not necessarily talking
about putting genes from another species.
We're not necessarily talking about
crossing genes between species.
It could be that we find some frogs out
there that already immune to cut trade
and we might be able to
use that genetic sequence.
But in fact that was kind of a moot point.
This idea of,
of using gene editing to kind of enhance
wildlife is actually a very logical
extinction to something that happens in
the natural world and in conservation
already. So in the natural world,
hybridization does occur between species,
not often, but it does certainly within
the bird world it's really quite common.
There was a study recently where they
analyze the DNA of a pile of birds and
found suspicious genes that
came from other species. Um,
and then the other thing
is that conservationists
are very conservative so I
could name and they tend not to
like things that are terribly new.
But one conservation practice that has
been going on for a long time is that
when populations of animals dwindled
down to very, very low numbers,
what they will do is introduce animals
from a separate population to introduce
genetic diversity.
And sometimes that occurs not
necessarily within species,
but within the subspecies.
So the Florida Panther is kind of a famous
example where the Florida panther was
seriously depleted in
numbers getting desperately.
And Brad and then this is a while ago,
people imported the Texas Panther and
they integrate and things got better as a
result. So this might seem
kind of new and unfamiliar,
but I would argue actually this is
something that happens naturally and
something that one of the scientist said
to me, look, a conservation biologist,
he said,
look,
for years and years people
have been solving this
problem by moving the animals.
I'm suggesting we move the jeans.
The end result is probably the same,
although maybe if we did it our way, we've
got a little bit more control over it.
I have a question.
Is anyone looking at bringing back plant
life or other fauna or flora rather
instead of just foreigner? I didn't
particularly look at plants in the book,
but um, what we have of course
are these amazing seed banks,
these repositories of
seeds where they're the,
they're trying to harvest as many seeds
as they can before plants go extinct.
And of course if you've got the seeds,
it's relatively straight forward. Um,
so I don't know about d
extincting plant life,
but going to the other end of the
spectrum where we're thinking about gene
editing, of course GM is
commonplace in the Arab world now,
but the first genetically modified trees,
the American chestnut and that had a
gene from wheat paste it into the gene of
the chestnut tree because it was suffering
from a particular type of blight that
was completely hammering
this type of tree. Um,
I'm there now at the stage in the states
now where they're considering they've
got test plots and they're considering
about how they might possibly return the
street to the wild.
Do you need DNA from both genders and
also be able to bring those pieces back
and how many individuals Dna do you
need in order to have enough diversity?
Do you need a male and a
female? Yes. So, you know,
this depends on us having som
Paul's in museums of mixed genders.
And if we don't,
maybe we think about hybridizing say
a northern white rhino with its living
cousin,
the southern White Rhino.
So you might not make a
pure northern white rhino,
but you at least save it's jeans and then
over time you can breed a pure animal
as time goes on. And in terms
of a founding population size,
we don't know.
Basically,
it depends on all sorts of things like
the generation time of the animal.
So the black footed ferret was presumed
extinct in the 1980s they thought it had
been wiped out by this place that was
killing it and they went out and call
every single last animal they could
find from the plains in Wyoming,
they brought 18 animals into captivity.
This was 1989 and it was seen as
this amazing conservation thing.
Nobody had ever gone out there and
captured all the members of species in the
wild and put them in captivity.
It was really radical for his.
The problem was that from these 18 found
a members only seven survived and 9,000
ferrets later through this
captive breeding project
that they have ongoing that
beginning to show signs of inbreeding,
but they have cells from some of the
original animals that were caught but that
for whatever reason didn't manage to
breed and they figure that if they manage
to create new animals from
two of those original animals,
they increased the size of the founding
population from seven to nine and they
think that will give them a decent
chance of enough genetic diversity.
But it's a question that
varies from species to species
and genetic diversity is
quite a stochastic random process.
So it has a lot to do with a
random shuffling of the genes.
When creatures reproduce,
you might be lucky and get away with a
very small founding number or in some
cases it might take a larger one.
Okay, a nice talk. Thank you very
much. Thank you. I have a question.
So you're talking about a lot,
there's a lot of technology to create a,
to recreate animals that are extinct.
Do we have debt amount of technology to
like predicting pact of this animal in
the Eh,
in the environment.
Because if we bring back the memos
and we put him somewhere, whatever,
somewhere that would be nice for him.
What can we expect from in destroying
everything else because there is an
imbalance there. Or like the Pgo like if
that, cause we have pigeon problem, right?
There's lots of pigeon.
If we put a new page on there,
what can happen? You can, we,
we have technology
tools to think about it,
to understand what might happen with this,
this dead end road coming
back and just want to think,
do you think that if someone finds
like is a very big piece of dinosaur,
like the fans from the move, maybe they
can come back. That would be awesome.
Like barn.
Okay.
All right. Well, so
the first question, um,
what day extinction but extinction at the
moment. Is it a process in development?
It's kind of at the cell biology state
and at the create an animal stage.
And what's missing,
in my opinion,
is this kind of long term thinking where
we start thinking about what happens
when these animals are released.
And that's not to say that
the thinking's not going on,
but that's a discussion that's
really just starting now.
And we need to cologists brought on in
these discussions from a really early
point. And not only that,
we need Paleo ecologist,
so we need people that have studied
these animals the first time around.
They've looked at their remains,
they've learned from what happened when
this animal was around the first time
around.
And certainly with the passenger pigeon,
that's something that's happening.
The Guy who's leading the passenger
pigeon project is a guy called Ben Novak,
and he's passionate about the project
and he's gone through all the historical
records and he has a very,
very clear idea of how passenger pigeons,
when they were alive,
interacted with their environment.
So they were like this
swarm of feathered locus.
These birds would land and devastate the
deciduous woodland where they landed,
which doesn't sound great, right? But bear
with me. So they would land on my ass,
they would topple trees, they would
cover the forest floor in Guano.
But from that apparent devastation
came life. So we're stagnant.
Closed canopy woodland turned into one
that was sunlit and the Guano fertilize
the ground and it paved the
way for the growth of, uh,
all sorts of different plants,
which brought in insects and
small mammals and amphibians,
which brought in big Grazers,
which brought in predators.
And he's modeled this whole thing very,
very carefully.
And he is pretty confident that because
the passenger patrion was such a key
stone species,
it's actions had these repercussions
across the entire landscape that if you
introduced it back into that environment,
it would drive this
recycling of the unknown.
The eastern North American forest that
has been absent since it's been gone.
But that's something we need to think
about really carefully. You know,
ultimately we don't know.
And ultimately we need to build that
in to the release of these animals.
We also need to think about our get
out plan for these animals. You know,
the world is,
is read riddled with invasive species
that are causing their responsible for
most of the extinctions that
are happening. Certainly
on islands there are big,
big problem.
You don't want anything that you go
to all this trouble of creating to be
considered a pest.
You don't have to kill it again.
So these are things that we need
to think about really carefully.
And I hope that answers
the first question.
And the second question is with dinosaurs.
There's a lady called Mary
Schweitzer in America who is, um,
she studies dinosaur bones and she seen
these really tantalizing glimpses of
biological molecules inside dinosaur
bones. So I wouldn't call them proteins,
but she sees signs of proteins,
she sees signs of sounds and our
results are pretty controversial and yet
they're beginning to be backed
up by some other groups.
There was a group at UCL last
year who found something similar.
People haven't really looked in dinosaur
bones for these kinds of biological
molecules because we've been taught at
school that they are in a, it's a mineral,
that they're inorganic. But that dogma
is potentially beginning to change now.
And she went even further.
Cause for her,
of course the natural progression
is to say could DNA be in there?
And she ran some tests on some quite
ancient dinosaur bones and sees signs of
DNA. So I'm not saying there's DNA
there, but she saw a signature of DNA.
However,
it's one thing for DNA maybe
to be there in fossils,
which is questionable fossils of that age.
It's quite another for it
to be in any usable form.
And I don't think we will ever get DNA
in a usable form from dinosaur bones.
You have to be able to
reconstruct the genetic sequence,
the genome to give you that set
of instructions to create life.
And would you like a pet dinosaur?
Me Too.
But sadly we're going to have to fell
for dogs and bring them into be back.
We're getting dogs to work and
dinosaurs that could get messy.
Alright. Thanks a lot for your time.
Thank you for thinking of engaging. Uh,
I have one question. It seems like the
biggest problem is having a source of DNA,
again from dangerous features, dishes.
Are we doing anything to treat?
I sort of bank for the future because if
it's not today, it's might be 100 years.
This techniques will be finalized on work.
So are we thinking about building this
instead of relying on single museums than
might have one species DNA
or something like that?
Are we doing something more global?
Yeah, so we've got this massive
repository of DNA in museums,
but it's much better to have frozen cells
because then you've got something that
is alive that you can start with.
It's far easier to start with DNA inside
a living cell than DNA inside a stuffed
museum specimen. So the museum
specimens are kind of like a,
a source of last recourse if you like.
What is really important are the viable
cells that are frozen and thoughts of
liquid nitrogen.
And there are multiple initiatives all
around the world are doing exactly what
you're thinking of.
The biggest one is at the San Diego Zoo
in America where they have something
called the frozen zoo and three
of those either but also three,
many other zoos and wildlife
collections around the world.
They send body parts to San Diego Zoo
and they culture these cells and they
freeze them.
And I heard the guy who leads this is a
guy called Oliver Ryder and I heard him
speak last year and he says he's always
getting interesting things in the post.
So partly there was some Orca at seaworld
or somewhere that had just given birth
and they grabbed the umbilical cord and
they packed it into her eyes and they
sent it to him when they called yourself
from that and they froze them down.
So yes,
and that's the interesting thing that
if we have these frozen cells in liquid
nitrogen, you have a species
maybe in Stacey's not quite alive,
not quite dead.
I mean clearly heard his dad,
but it's not as dead as some other things.
So yes,
people are trying to collect as much
biodiversity as they possibly can and
squirrel it away for a rainy day.
And it's not just, they're actually,
I should say the main points of these
things is not really there for bringing
animals,
but to lock it.
The main reason for the cells being
collected is to use them as a source of
learning. They used in research
papers all around the world,
but by studying DNA
from endangered species,
you get an idea of the health
of these endangered species.
You can see if they're going
through a genetic bottleneck,
it can give you some idea of how to manage
your captive breeding programs so the
cells that are being frozen away are
being used for all sorts of excellent
purposes and de extinction is maybe just
a glint in the eye somewhere off to the
side of that, but it could be
used for that in the future.
Hey,
we got the same on the same line.
It's just a,
is it just going to be edited?
It's going to be a muffin or an Lmr.
No, you're quite right. It won't be.
If Georgia church has his way,
he's not easy not calling it a mammoth.
He's saying he's making a cold adapted
elephant. He's making an elephant, his,
his creature.
And I should also say none
of these creatures that get
to extincted if and when
that happens, we'll be the same as the
original. It's been many, many reasons,
many reasons. One of the
reasons is their genetic makeup.
So George Church is an extreme
example where he will end up,
if he succeeds in his quest with
an animal that is genetically,
overwhelmingly elephant with a
little sprinkling of mammoth DNA.
But he says, well, Hey, I'm
completely fine with that.
So long as this animal acts like a
wooly mammoth and can perform the same
ecological role as a woolly mammoth
when we put it back. So in to Siberia.
And I don't have a problem with that
and that's the way the day extinction
community feels. It's not about
creating an absolute replica.
It's about something that will
fulfill a lost ecological niche out.
A really quick question about the, uh,
the pregnancy or the surrogacy rather, um,
say for example, with the,
with the Baccato was, how
do you select the animal to,
to kind of carry the Dakota go to
time? Is it something, is it a seminar,
mountain goat with you know that she has
a lot of the DNA or also for the woolly
mammoth, would that potentially
be an elephant or how, how
does that process, yeah,
what you need to do is you need to find
the closest living relative. So, you know,
I said it's great if you can bring back
an animal that is genetically distinct,
but of course the,
the,
the problem there is that if it is
genetically distinct and unique,
what do you use as a surrogate?
Which is where something like a frog is
great because you don't need a surrogate.
You know,
you could if you don't need a you and
you've removed a whole lot of problems.
Now with the big Cardo, they used
obviously an existing type of goat.
They had to create a particular hybrid
because they'd be Kardos closest living
relative ended up being really flirty
and difficult to look after in captivity.
And it literally climbed the
walls and were so neurotic.
I couldn't work with that.
So they created a hybrid guy where they
bred it's closest living relative with a
domestic goat. And found that that worked
really well as a surrogate. So I mean,
when I, when I give these
talks, you only get,
you don't get a flavor of the huge amount
of research and effort that goes into
what happens.
So just choosing the right surrogate and
getting it to work was massive for the
Bucardo team.
And yet with a wooly mammoth,
my big problem with a wooly mammoth is
that it involves using elephant eggs,
which are in really, really short
supply and elephants as surrogates. Now,
there is one potential way around
getting hold of elephant eggs.
Scientists are now in this position
where they can take skin cells,
we program them into stem cells
and use them to generate and sperm,
right? So that potentially is a very
exciting tool we have at our fingertips.
It's been demonstrated in mice at
the whole process, hasn't been shown,
particularly for endangered species,
but people are working on that.
So maybe we can get hold
of a load of elephant eggs,
perform these techniques on,
but then you still need a surrogate. And
I don't feel good about that. You know,
elephants are seriously in danger.
They're not experimental animals.
And George Church, who was amazing,
we'll say to you, come on.
Think bigger. Think bigger.
Think, think artificial womb.
Okay?
Until we get to that point, or until
the elephants out of it, you know what?
I'm never going to be comfortable with
using an elephant as a surrogate. For me,
that is a massive stumbling
block with a wooly mammoth.
And we need to think about
the repercussions of every,
we can't sacrifice one endangered species
to bring back another from the dead.
So will all of these questions need
to be thought about really deeply
with that.
Please join me in a massive unopposed
[inaudible].